when you think about physics today has
it changed for the better or for the
worse in terms of conflict that we now
see move to social media on Twitter I
know you're not on that which is why
you're so productive nowadays we see
like these battles like today there's a
battle about life on Venus and it's
being waged on Twitter what do you make
of that compared to your battles in
person string theory is a contribution
to science contribution to anti-science
it takes place on the blogosphere I do
from time to time read some of it I
think is very very destructive it's
foolish it's silly largely the people
don't know what the hell they're talking
about and especially if you read the
commentary that comes after the things
that the bloggest says they can be
indicillin they can truly be in Basilica
but what does it do what does its not a
thing I think it adds to the sense that
you can't trust scientists
[Music]